giorno o mangiando ha mai sono il verde
però convinto di essere il giallo bene a
tutti ragazzi benvenuto sono morto le
mete questo video sono fi james siamo su
steve fight the game
e sono partito male perché stavo
mangiando per la parte quello ei non
puoi battermi sempre no non ci credo
come possibile lo ha fatto vivere un
consiglio non è possibile solo vivo bene
subito stabilire che la supremazia sono
io il verde
in tutto questo ma non avevo capito di
essere verde ho capito solo quando sono
molto 26 volte basta stare tranquilli
nessuno viene a romperti le balle
praticamente questa era è la tecnica che
uso ne lascio schiacciare
poi uno ci allarma finale però se ti sei
comportato bene il karma non ti punisce
teoricamente questo è quello che penso
no ho vinto raga tre di fila sono un
fenomeno sto gioco online con ragazzine
non pone non facevo seafight per
l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto racca non
so se lo ricordate ma c'è la mia madre
che sta facendo il letto e quindi non
son riuscito a commentarlo e vennero
invito totalmente muto
oggi voglio provare a farlo commentando
l'ultima volta mi ha aiutato a
concentrarvi un sacco
vediamo se oggi anche come tanto riesco
a fare qualcosa di decente
va bene faccio finta di niente
combattete tra di voi ai a madonna che
male attenzione sbaglia stai buono alla
stele volata cielo menaye meno agli me
lei è mai è bravo ma come mattina tua
testata in bocca sono morto ma come ma
se l'altro ma scusami se io gli oli
quando quando colpisco io non faccio
così male come possibile perché quando
la gente colpisce me mi faccio così male
basta toccarmi la lancia ai a me lo sono
meritato questi avanti a santa siano per
le uo perché il rosso è venuto lamento
perché perché siete stupidi by prendila
no no però ci credo mio privato è stato
bravissimo va bene ma guarda merita
morte meritata
ragazzi no perché non avrei mai detto è
riuscito ad andare a prendere allarme e
uccidermi perché io pensavo di avere
molto più tempo
e invece no bravo è stato furbo come
questo qua è tutto un a schivare cose
alla fine storicamente dovrei riuscirci
a meno che non vada rompere le balle
stavo per morire tantissimo fa niente ai
ragazzi la vedo molto più adrenalinica
dell'ultima volta quindi dovrei fargli
spesso si fa effettivamente poi che
qualche volta mi ha dato anche
abbastanza bene però non ho detto nulla
anche commentando non male ok quello si
schiaccia si schiaccia no aiuto barca ma
come porca vacca al raggio ragazzi non
avete capito potete andare dall'altra
parte c'è il blu è andato la parte
sbagliatissima
aiuto aiuto occhio ai a sono morto per
chi è rimasto rimasto solo lui perché lo
fa continuare se rimasto solo lui
qual è il problema che è rimasto vivo ma
c'è ancora blu come se pagato il blu
ragazzi lui è rimasto vivo in qualche
modo siamo ragazze nokia luogo che avevo
tanto glow teoricamente non è offensivo
non è vero invece limitato offensivo a
caso è morto una pistola testata
fortissimo aperto sta soltando tipo
cristiano ronaldo se mi metto dietro il
cespuglio nessuno mi vede non è vero mi
hanno visto
[Musica]
rimanendo nascosto tutto il tempo
bellissimo
raga sono stati che vi sto gioco per
rimanere nascosti e veramente un'ottima
tattica tranne quando i serpenti teen
inglobano però vabbè ajax riguardare
anche mezzo io non sono gli altri occhio
occhio la voleva e non la prende forse
dovevo andare un po più cauto forse però
fa niente raga purtroppo mi faccio
prendere la mano dalle cose giganti che
senso allora devo aspettare che mi
arrivi nar ma se mi arriva eccola aiuto
lo fa lipidi recall biraga prova a
schivarli tutti ce l'ho fatta un vero
jedi e non è morto no sì sì sì sì mi
sono salvata all'ultimo incredibile
niente niente ho sbagliato codato
sbagliato lato lato sbagliato lato ho
sbagliato lato lato elkann mi sa che
sono un pelo nella cacca aiuto ho
provato a puntargli lo sparo non sono
riuscito a mai vabbè maledizione società
è diventato veramente competitivi
io a posto ma niente portate che vinco
io ha di fronte va eliminato subito
comunque ok perfetto perfetto ma devo
resistere non rimanere lì deve rimanere
devo rimanere su proprio lui era giallo
fk adesso va beh io rimango fuori e
litigate tra di voi è rimasto vivo solo
il giallo che rimasto fermo finora dato
non arrivi di persone che muovermi io ho
un buon giorno facciamo che va vicino la
donna fa malissimo con la roma di testa
al 9 madonna
una volta attenzione no gli ho tirato un
calcio qua ed è morto non si sa come va
bene ragazzi ottimo la partenza occhio
al blu madonna madonna con una garanzia
giallo
no ho vinto il blu ci siamo suicidati
giallo non doveva colpirmi così ci siamo
ragazzi abbiamo preso il via per bene
quindi occhio giallo ti devi togliere
pensa agli altri non sembra me porca
vacca non me l'aspettavo mai no questo è
orribile ragazzi questa è orribile
lui è caduto subito forti o giallo
giallo il rosso proprio lui li smash
vabbè mi segnando comunque basso
prendendo veramente sul serio
vai tranquillo continua spararti da solo
io il giallo no
madonna controlli così per i serpenti li
odio perché la fine non servono a niente
però importante di miccoli attenzione
quali la palla ma mori rimini che muore
lui di me che moreno morello di dirmi
che noi siamo morti tutti e due ceppi
non è morto
non è morto ma come cioè alla fine ha
fatto tutto lui è sopravvissuto vabbè
dai ci siamo questa buona non adesso
subito proprio immediatamente armi aiuto
armin fa a.cam e giacche bot
quello si è suicidato per non morire
così bravo a proprio da questa
bellissima perché anche la gittata
madonna fate voi sparatevi tra di voi io
non ne voglio sapere dove di sparare
prima lui getta mai power le avrebbe
effettivamente non mio dio non ci credo
sono stupido se vinci tu mi incazzo
ecco perché non è impossibile c'è un
coltellino 8
nessuno l'ha preso iovino rimango qua
aspetto che mi ammazzate due canzoni di
blocco sulla spada è no oddio sante va
beh quando non puoi prendere le armi
stai kg e la madonna tutto a posto
giallo vai tu a prenderla quella perché
non la prendo mai tu io mi sono io sono
attaccato con la lingua sul muro arrivo
sono io a questo gioco bellissimo mare
dai raga facciamo le ultime due
proprio così buttate così attenzione c'è
un rinculo suo fucile io c'è una paura
fate voi ecco perfetto il fucile a pompa
non l'uso su più volte che muoio fa 10
riesce a scalzare il rosso che si
suicida perché ci ha paura è bellissimo
va bene mi sa che manca l'ultima questa
qua no si esca vincere anche l'ultima
sono è stato comunque un'ottima partita
ha vinto un sacco di match
effettivamente non mi posso lamentare
però attenzione il fucile a pompa sono
vivo ma è crollato dai ragazzi è stata
la bellissima sfida vale facciamo
l'ultima volta che ci siamo viste finiti
in fretta l'ultima l'ultima però mi
piace minori serpenti perché è inutile
cioè non è non è inutile in realtà vedo
che è abbastanza utile però preferisco
le armi normali perché i serpenti alla
fine hai rotto le palle giallo e da due
ore che rompi sono vivo io tremo sarah
viva non ci credo basta basta dopo
questa vittoria
basta cioè proprio il massimo prove vi
sia piaciuto sono stato molto bravo
rispetto al solito quindi bravo me spero
vi sia giunta ragazzi iscritti perché
mai le schiacciate il tasto mi piace e
la campanina come sempre per rimanere
aggiornati suoi video che escono era
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]